bienvenidos a multiplicación nivel 4
hagamos unos ejercicios entonces voy a
tomar el 235 y lo voy a multiplicar por
un número de dos dígitos para esto voy a
utilizar dos colores así que te aparece
el 40 y el 47 47 ok iniciamos con este
ejercicio y justo como lo haríamos en
unen en multiplicación nivel 3 ajá
tomamos el 7 y el 7 va a multiplicar a
cada uno de los dígitos en 235 así que 7
por 5 es igual a 35 7 por 3 es igual a
21 3 que llevamos eso es igual a 24
llevo 2 ahora 7 por 2 es igual a 14 más
2 que llevamos eso es igual a 16 y
terminamos con el 7 ahora vamos con el 4
aquí voy a poner un cero porque no
estamos multiplicando por 4 estamos
multiplicando por 40 ya que el 4 está en
el lugar de las décimas así que por eso
pongo el 0 en ese lugar aunque cabe
mencionar que una vez que pusiste el
cero a ella simplemente puedes enfocarte
en el 4 y multiplicar por 4 entonces 4
por 5 es igual a 20 ignoramos ignoramos
todo esto a 4 por 3 es igual a 12 2 que
llevamos es igual a 14
y 4 por 2 es igual a 81 eso es igual a 9
9 y simplemente sumamos todo esto 50 es
igual a 540 es igual a 4 6-4 es igual a
10 llevamos 11 más uno es igual a 2 más
9 es igual a 11 y la respuesta es 11 mil
45 hagamos hagamos otro ejemplo digamos
que tengo voy a inventar un número
grande 873 x por otro número grande
ahora estoy estoy poniendo números en
diferente color para que más o menos se
dé otro o un mejor entendimiento al
menos yo esperaría entonces qué te
parece x 97 no mejor no porque el 7 lo
acabo de utilizar entonces 98 98 queda
perfecto ahora justo como lo hicimos en
el ejemplo anterior vamos a al lugar de
las unidades el 8 va a multiplicar a
cada uno de los dígitos en 873 entonces
8 por 3 es igual a 24
y 8 por 7 es igual a 56 más 2 que
llevamos eso es igual a 58 8 por 8 es
igual a 64 más 5 que llevamos es igual a
69 y ya terminamos con el 8
ahora vamos a multiplicar por nueve a
cada uno de los dígitos ahora
multiplicar el 9 aquí como está en un
lugar de las décimas es como multiplicar
por 90 pero multiplicar por 90 es
simplemente multiplicar por 9 y agregar
un 0 no sé si te confundí pero bueno
multiplicamos por 9 873 entonces 9 por 3
es igual a 27 llevamos 2 9 por 7 es
igual a 63 más 2 que llevamos es igual a
65 9 por 8 es igual a 72 más 6 que
llevamos eso es igual a 78
y seguimos vamos a sumar aquí y aquí es
4 aquí es 15 llevamos 115 otra vez sí 8
+ 7 es otra vez 15 y ahora finalmente
aquí es 8
la respuesta es 85 mil 554 muchos 15 es
de verdad ok pero hagamos otro hagamos
otro voy a borrar esto adiós a esto y el
siguiente problema que voy a hacer casi
lo puedes ver como un ejercicio de nivel
5 pero no te espantes yo lo que quiero
que veas es un patrón y vas a ver aquí
un patrón de ese se hace igual se hace
igual voy a multiplicar un número de
tres dígitos por otro de tres dígitos y
vas a ver que es lo mismo entonces 234 x
y el 3 multiplicar a cada uno de los
dígitos en 234 entonces 3 por 4 es igual
a 12 llevo 13 por 3 es igual a 9 más uno
que llevamos eso es igual a 10 3 por 2
es igual a 6 más uno es igual a 7 y ya
terminamos de hecho creo que cometí un
error en haber feo esto 3 por 4 es igual
a 12 no de hecho está bien está bien es
que soy algo despistada pero pero
estamos bien ok entonces seguimos con el
4 el 4 o el 40 como como tú lo quieras
ver porque este en lugar de las décimas
entonces pongo simplemente un cero aquí
y ya ha arreglado
entonces multiplicamos por cuatro todo
esto y voy a borrar estoy aquí 4x4 es
igual a 16 ajá 4 por 3 es igual a doce
más uno que llevamos es igual a 13
y llevamos 14 por 2 es igual a 81 es
igual a 9 y ya terminamos con el 440
como tú lo quieras ver ahora seguimos
con el 6 o 600 porque como está en el
lugar de las centenas entonces pongo dos
ceros aquí y lo vemos como un simple 6
ahora voy a borrar esto y multiplicó 6
por 4 es igual a 24 6 por 3 es igual a
18 más 2 que llevamos es igual a 20 6
por 2 es igual a 12 más 2 es igual a 14
14 aquí ahora sumamos esto sumamos tengo
aquí 26
73 es igual a 10 más 4 es igual a 14 9
más uno es igual a 10 41 es igual a 5 y
1 entonces la respuesta es 150 mil 462
ya estás listo para hacer
multiplicaciones nivel 4 y tal vez nivel